in Watsonville California several
hundred Mexican Americans attend a
professional wrestling event
what exactly does lucha libre de have to
do with immigration policy in the main
event Mexican wrestler Annabelle junior
takes on a Border Patrol agent known as
el patron de La Migra you come here see
La Migra you frown upon them you want a
boom you want to scream anything you see
the ultimate good guy which should be
which is for Mexico
Latinos from the community with local
hero systems
America is the number one country in the
world we have a standard of living
unparalleled in the history of mankind
and that's why they swim crawl and
scrape and hop fences to come here
that's a Mexican what do you want me to
think about Border Patrol I don't I just
think they're mean they're evil the bad
persons fact that I get to berate a
bunch of illegal Mexicans and peach
Pickers all over the Central Valley I
get to go all over the world and berate
Mexicans I mean there's nothing there's
nothing better that I can think of they
wake up in the morning no that's what
I'm gonna do that's the job for me
that's what I was put on this earth to
do believe it I'm gonna enjoy it I'm
gonna enjoyed this as a kid
they know the potential my power and
they know I love my people I love Mexico
it's Batman and the Joker it's Superman
and kryptonite you have the ultimate
good which is ultimate bad and for the
most part our shows are targeted to the
Latino community so the luchador is for
the most part or the good guy but after
the cameras are off when there's lights
turn off when it shows over
you'd be surprised that small little
line by the locker room having Latinos
want the autographs from La Migra
think twice before you mess with el
patron de La Migra Oliver John is the
best of the best
Mexicans fear me because I am your
master
I am el patron and don't ever forget it
viva la migra we have a right as a
country to protect our borders as far as
who comes in but these people have
dreams and if they're fighting tooth and
nail to come here and make a better life
isn't that what this country is about
the melting pot
you